foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
diving into the history of auras how do
you stop a dark wizard especially when
you don't have the likes of Harry Potter
and his friends to help you out well for
much of Wizarding history the defense of
the magical world fell to a small
handful of powerful Ministry workers
tasked with one simple goal the
enforcement of Wizarding laws those
responsible were known as auras or dark
wizard hunters and even though you've
probably heard about them plenty of
times you've likely never heard their
full history and that's the tale we'll
tell today Origins while the ancient
history of quidditch takes up more than
a few bookshelves at the local shop in
Diagon Alley you might be surprised by
the utter lack of texts regarding auras
and that's a bit strange isn't it after
all knowing the exact date for the first
appearance of a golden snitch or these
specific legislation that limited games
around medieval muggle Villages isn't
really that important at least not when
compared to the life and death
consequences of anti-dark Arts police
work but the history of auras is
shrouded in mystery they first appeared
in text in the 18th century the British
Minister for magic at the time a wizard
named Eldritch diggery was the first
person to officially create an aura's
office and so at a glance you might be
tempted to Guess that the ministry of
magic didn't have auras at all until
that point and you wouldn't be wrong to
think that but the duty of an aura the
apprehension of dark Wizards and other
criminals was likely just grouped into
the role of other Ministry officials
that meant other members of the official
Wizarding government especially those
within the department of magical law
enforcement fulfilled the day-to-day
tasks that auras would eventually do but
thanks to the work of Minister Eldritch
diggery the jobs of wizards and witches
at the ministry of magic became more
specialized and instead of bullying your
average office worker into enforcing
magical laws diggery created a brand new
office of auras and ever since that
fateful day in the early 18th century
the auras have gone on to become one of
the most feared and beloved aspects of
the ministry of magic history now you
obviously know that the auras did much
more than fight against dark wizards but
that can be a bit hard to remember
especially when the most famous Aura of
the 21st century Harry Potter had
achieved so much in his campaigns
against the Death Eaters and Lord
Voldemort but in the decades and
centuries that followed the creation of
the aura's office that small sector of
magical law enforcement officials took
on a whole boatload of different crimes
from quelling Goblin rebellions to
investigating the illegal trade of
magical creatures the auras were both
The Wizarding worlds police force and
the closest thing to a standing army
that the ministry would ever mobilize
only decades after the aura's office was
created one of their very owns elected
to lead the entire Ministry of magic
this talented wizard a cunning duelist
known as Hephaestus Gore came into power
at a particularly tumultuous time the
British magical Community was still
quite wary of the ministry of magic
after all not even 50 years had passed
since the wizard gamut had evolved into
the ministry and far fewer years since
the ministry started to patrol The
Wizarding World and strictly enforced
laws on magical beings in centuries
prior the wizard gamut hadn't exactly
been eager in Prosecuting cases against
criminals just like courts in the Muggle
world the wizard gamut seemed to be
driven by public pressure and was always
happy to look the other direction when
petty crime was involved but the new
ministry of magic was different its
binding agreements with International
Wizarding governments like the
international statute of Wizarding
secrecy forced the aura's hand in order
to honor their deals with foreign
Nations and also to keep the peace the
auras went on the hunt for crime and
that meant it was only a matter of time
before magical beings around Britain
decided that they didn't like the idea
of the ministry and its auras suddenly
telling them what was right and wrong
and devised as Gore was caught in the
middle of it when he was elected to
power the goblins revolted and sensing
an opportunity to overthrow the wizard
elitist government the werewolves joined
in as well but feister's Gore wasn't a
pushover he was one of the earliest
auras in the entire magical law
enforcement department with specialized
knowledge on the psychology and
weaknesses of every magical being in
Britain Gore managed to lead the
ministry to Victory and started A
Century Of Peace in the British
Wizarding Community From the Ashes of
that fateful Rebellion the ministry's
influence over the British Wizarding
World strengthened its laws and its law
enforcement became the bogeyman for
every magic user in its domain which was
most definitely a good thing it's easy
to look back at the years before the
auras and fill a Pang of nostalgia as we
think about all the Twisted Tales of
dark Wizards and forests infested with
evil vampires the world before the
aura's department certainly seemed like
a more adventurous place but for the
average Wizarding wedge who just wanted
to raise their family in a safe
environment the joys between a world
with auras and one without was a
no-brainer to them the stronger the
auras and the department of magical law
enforcement became the better after
Minister Gore successfully quelled that
Rebellion until grindelwald's Global
Wizarding war in the early to mid 20th
century the aura's department stayed
relatively quiet they patrolled the
alleys and Villages of the British was a
World killed a few werewolves and
banished countless criminals to Azkaban
but it wasn't all as peaceful as it
seemed at least that was true for any
non-wizard or wedge if you asked any
Goblin how self or Centaur what they
thought of the ministry and their auras
you might be surprised by what you'd
hear because to them there was no
difference between a dark Wizard and a
collar striped Aura both represented
Wizard elitism and both oppressed
non-wizard kind when the dark wizard
Gaelic Grindelwald decided to hunt down
the Deathly Hallows and then later tried
to take over the Wizarding World the
British ministry's auras were sent into
battle This Global Wizarding War which
lasted from the 1920s until the early
1940s
saw Britain's auras transform into a
paramilitary force they took their
defense against the dark art skills
along with their dueling expertise and
used it to pursue Grindelwald from
continent to continent in the end it was
Albus Dumbledore the future Headmaster
of Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry who ended the war by defeating
Grindelwald and for the next three
decades the ministry's auras returned to
Britain where they continued to patrol
the Cobblestone roads of Diagon Alley
and keep an eye on the dark Wizards and
witches but it wouldn't be long until
another dark wizard this time a native
of Britain would rise to threaten the
ministry in the 1970s Tom Riddle
recruited an army of followers this
group which he called Death Eaters and
terrorized the British Wizarding
community and the auras desperate to
stop them did something which had been
Unthinkable up to that point they
started to use the unforgivable cursor
Avada Kedavra crucio and imperio when
Lord Voldemort Was Defeated on Halloween
night in 1981 the auras managed to gain
the upper hand they rounded up the
surviving Death Eaters and brought them
before the Wizarding courts by that
point the major conflict of this first
Wizarding War had concluded and the
auras disbanded their wartime structure
and returned to regular magical law
enforcement work but when Voldemort
returned in the 1990s he attacked the
auras with a cunning strike the dark
lord wisely decided to infiltrate the
ministry with Death Eaters or by using
the imperious curse on unsuspecting
Ministry workers this allowed him to get
rid of the auras almost entirely and
with Britain's dark wizard Hunters out
of the picture Voldemort only had one
obstacle Harry Potter as we all know
Voldemort's plan didn't exactly work out
Harry Potter defeated him and the Death
Eaters one once again were rounded up
and dispatched to Azkaban in the
aftermath of the final battle that
second Wizarding War those who fought
against Voldemort were offered roles in
the newly opened auras department and
many of Hogwarts Defenders including
Harry Potter gladly accepted it wouldn't
take long for Harry to climb through the
ranks of the ministry either which
honestly was a welcome change for so
much of Harry Potter's Life The
Wizarding World had treated him with
mistrust early on the ministry of magic
was wary of what Harry represented a
lingering question was the Voldemort
threat truly over and even after the
dark lord regained his physical form and
attacked Harry Potter the ministry
refused to acknowledge that another War
could possibly begin and all of their
lies in gaslighting LED Harry into one
of the darkest periods of his life but
after Voldemort's death the ministry
became at least a Harry what it was
always meant to be a heroic defender of
wizards across Britain and in less than
a decade Harry's own heroic career as
Nora brought him the biggest promotion
in the history of the ministry he became
director of the aura's department at
only 26 or 27 years of age Legacy or as
our heroes at least that's what you'll
hear if you ask the Wizards and witchers
who depend on them without auras the
magical world in Britain would be a far
more dangerous place to navigate they
successfully put down monstrous revolts
and they raised their wands against
hordes of dark Wizards if you do some
simple math and calculate how many
innocent lives the auras must have saved
it's hard to see them as anything other
than noble soldiers perhaps that's the
only way we should remember them but to
others like the Goblins who were tired
of being treated like second-class
citizens and the werewolves who were
simply victims of the horrible
lycanthropy infection
auras might not have been knights in
shining armor do these magical beings
our favorite magical law enforcement
might have been nothing more than
monsters and that's it for this video
did you have any more questions about
the history of auras did I miss anything
leave a comment down below as always if
you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live
foreign